I've got some fun questions in here
where you guys play the game with me
spell some Secrets give me some teeth
were you
at the model one choose one okay choose
one thank you okay okay let me you go
first because I need to figure out this
one okay what cartoon character do you
see as a style icon oh do you know how
to say Marge Simpson oh wow take away
take away the
[Applause]
read them and dress on
that kind of chic
I like it that wasn't what I was gonna I
was I wasn't expecting okay GG what's
your question
name a time you faked it till you made
it oh and I will say next in fashion
like I I went on my first on my first
day of work and like you know we have to
learn the script how how to like speak
you know with our producers and and um
you like that yes what we do is to make
it look like someone's not talking to us
the whole time so you're going
mid-conversation like Drew's doing
pretending like she's listening to me
but really she's having a fully
different conversation in her head yes
talking to someone else so that I fully
I mean we had you know like a rehearsal
day but my my first episode on that show
is me faking that I knew what the heck
was going on well I watched that first
episode and I thought you were
phenomenal thank you so much
another question
tan thank you love what's your question
who was your first celebrity crush you
know we were just talking about this in
the green room so I'm gonna say just the
the top of my mind Brandon Fraser in
that Tarzan movie oh George is a drum
ball yeah man well he's all oiled up and
in a loin cloth
yeah yeah really I'm so shocked
GG you go what is a life moment you want
to relive
oh so I did um a few years back four
collections for Tommy Hilfiger we did a
collection I remember
um and our first show was
um at the seaport in New York City yep
and we put on like a carnival but I
remember being like so overwhelmed by
the moment that I I feel like I didn't
fully experience it
so like it wasn't it just like happened
really fast and I just remember being I
wish I just like took it in more at the
end of Ferris Bueller he says life moves
pretty fast if you don't stop and take a
look around every once in a while yeah
and that was and I I always look back on
that moment and I'm like take it in I'm
like feel it I have this wait I know
that I know that we're probably running
late but I've got a story for one minute
yeah a woman that we've been friends for
years that you do not know okay that
first show you did I was just regular
tan yeah and I snuck into the tomahaw
figure show to meet you
I went back to Stage we met and I asked
for a photo I met you that day
after this we never know each other
now um we heard that there's a fashion
trend that Gigi and I happen to like we
heard you do not like I said I'd say
we're icons in the matter of this
particular right well we we have a
little gift for you oh get out I don't
want it I actually don't want it
now can you refuse a gift no thank you
take it to the trash I know exactly now
with me
oh I I don't like either of you I think
can I put them on just to show how
obvious they are
[Applause]
hi
friends
[Applause]
you can watch season two of next in
fashion now on Netflix I am binging it
as we speak it is the best show ever
please enjoy it enjoy them
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]